despite what you might think this movie
has nothing to do with how to train your
personal dragon my little bezel blob
that I have this [ __ ] can't get
him under control he's the reason but
all these wars are going on and Iraq
right now Afghanistan
I really gotta fall politics to make my
political humor a lot more clever How to
Train Your Dragon and part DOS this film
was incredible look I'll admit right up
front like right now at the very front
of this row I was not mesmerized by the
first no sir mmm-hmm but I thought this
film was truly beautiful like a mermaid
the story is great these are just a
whole bunch of villains bad guys world
of dragons ah it's my dragon impression
not one dragon sounds like that in the
entire movie and it's all fantastic look
a lot of the great stuff I want to talk
about will be you like spoilers so I
can't get into you know too much detail
I can't use examples to illustrate my
point even more let me try to do this
visually the film is just beautiful a
lot of my favorite scenes were like the
dragon exploring scenes go into dragon
world going on the dragon coaster
Legoland
that was [ __ ] awesome it's an
animated movie but yet it's a very
immersive world I found myself going wow
no way that's beautiful with that can't
get the [ __ ] out of the goddamn row he's
standing and making all this [ __ ]
noise get the [ __ ] out of the way you
little [ __ ] can't [ __ ] see the screen
because of you kids they made the
animation even better than before and
the characters that we got to know in
love we know even more hey go ah he just
starts off like a badass in this movie
he's not really able to be in sync with
his dragon
he's got weapons and [ __ ] now he could a
bit of facial hair to establish that he
has grown older and is more of a man
he's awesome but he still has like that
incredible heart that really cares about
people but being like that in real life
is a whole other thing you will get your
heart shattered and this dragon
toothless that's what I call it every
late
I've ever been with a toothless
toothless is still adorable and badasses
ever part combo to have but adorable
badass that's who toothless is gonna
love toothless he reminds you of a cat I
just want to pet him he's one of the
coolest animated characters ever
I even like Willy do with Nichols dad
played by Gerard Butler I talked to this
side of my mouth every movie it's my
natural way of speaking like I said I
don't want to give anything away but
they feature him more and you get to
explore aspects to him we didn't get it
explore before I just arrived damn dude
going on all these rhymes making all
this time wanna drink a lemon have it a
little bead lime I want to do something
so I pick out this dime snort some coke
and wouldn't you know I got another joke
and I got this rope around my neck as
the [ __ ] I cannot forget I think I let
my pain just take over my brain but what
am I gonna do when I think of you when
all the hell did you put me through well
I say I do the do well let down some
Mountain Dew when I'm gonna tell you
that right now you don't [ __ ] with the
wrong dude carried away there but yeah
you do see more signs to draw Butler the
new character that truly stood out to me
was hiccup some mom now hiccup badass
toothless badass when hiccups mom bold
for a badass she's got tight ass to look
through that ass as well [ __ ]
I hope kids are watching this review so
they can know what adults turn into you
see more of why hiccup is the way he is
because you see how his mother is how am
I going in detail but it's pretty
interesting its voice wonderfully by
Kate Blanchette how did I say blonde
[ __ ] or blonde [ __ ] I really like the
villain - blonde pissed or as I call it
once a month you actually don't see him
so very late into the film I like that
blood fist joke a lot but they built up
this guy's character so well I don't
call an enemy in a movie pulling it off
so well like they really built this guy
up me edified him and everything and
then you're like this guy's already
terrifying we don't even know he looks
like yet all you know is this
[ __ ] is just collecting dragons
this son of a [ __ ] some bad shits about
to go down and when [ __ ] goes down it is
awesome visually just just that's really
thrilling
maurizio right now and she did not feel
this way about the movie first time I
ever wanted to kill Marie was when we
argued about how to
you're dragging to literally apply the
whole thing I was gonna take her body
cut it up into several pieces and this
is [ __ ] I've already imagined prior to
that night you know it's just the
thought of killing Marie has always
sounded really fun to me what impresses
me the most about this film is that it
was written and directed by one guy one
person wrote and directed all that crap
that is amazing whoever you are kudos to
you man [ __ ] love you that is mad
respect dog you might home boy skillet
it's right when you make them no it's
not as funny as the first one it's not
but there's some good jokes there were
some good jokes Murray I liked how they
made this sequel darker like any [ __ ]
sequel does actually but in this one it
really does add to the film a lot like
it does and the music is incredible joy
to the world the Lord has come don't
make it come joke make it come true you
will have said a lot of people I found
myself very moved by this movie like
it's truly a family film a film where
kids will love it but there are some
stuff that adults might you know yet
more
I love how fast-paced it was it was like
only now on 40 minutes but you felt like
you wanted an epic adventure that's what
it felt like Murray shut up Murray it's
one truly amazing film I almost even
cried a couple times what's next -
Alyssa - she cries like a whale who's
horny that made sense let me get
straight to the point here oh no I gotta
say how the Train Your Dragon 2 got it
super duper dragon flyer right
alright guys thanks for checking out my
review before out did I don't know I
mean this was how to train your dragon -
why don't you go ahead and you scroll
that comment box below and tell me have
you ever been with a toothless before
and yeah I want to throw out there you
can follow me on twitter and you can
follow the real rejects on Twitter and a
bunch of the other rejects on Twitter
there's Facebook like you know what okay
last but not least if you want to get
updated every time one of my reviews
their videos is up go ahead and clear
this butter by my dick to subscribe uh
let me say something about this little
dragon he has trained all kinds of
toothless to do right does that work Oh
take two here we go we do something
about this little dragon whatever he is
with a certain woman that he just cannot
resist his penis gets set on fire once a
month trying to do a chlamydia joke here
yeah yeah exactly that's what I'm trying
to do I find it it's like really close
he says I have this little traction